SPEAKER KEVIN McCARTHY
YESTERDAY, AND WHAT DO WE KNOW
MORE ABOUT THIS PLAN AND THE
DECISION.
>> YEAH, THIS IS FIRST SIGN THAT
GEORGE SANTOS HAS RECOGNIZED
THAT HE COULD BE IN TROUBLE
HERE.
HE HAS BEEN DEFIANT HERE ALL
ALONG AND SAYING THAT HE HAS
NOTHING TO HIDE AND MOVING
FORWARD AS A NORMAL MEMBER OF
CONGRESS DESPITE ADMITTING TO
LIES AND QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
CAMPAIGN FINANCE AND NEW
REVELATIONS THAT ARE COMING OUT
DAILY THAT HAVE HURT THIS
EMBATTLED CONGRESSMAN AND
THREATEDED THE CAREER HERE IN
CONGRESS, AND NOW HE IS TELLING
THE CONFERENCE BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS THAT HE IS NOT GOING TO BE
SERVING ON TWO KEY COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS THAT WERE GIVEN TO
HIM BY THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
AND THE TOP ALLIES DESPITE THE
PUSHBACK AND CONCERNS THAT HE
WOULD SIT ON THESE COMMITTEES,
AND HE MADE IT CLEAR TO THE
CONFERENCE THAT HE WOULD STEP
ASIDE UNTIL THE LEGAL ISSUES ARE
RESOLVED AND THE HOUSE SCIENCE
COMMITTEE AND THE HOUSE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WILL BE
WHERE HE IS STEPPING ASIDE.
AND MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE WHO I
JUST CAUGHT UP WITH SAID HOW HIS
MESSAGE WAS RECEIVED.
>> HE JUST FELT LIKE THAT THERE
WAS SO MUCH DRAMA REALLY OVER
THE SITUATION, AND ESPECIALLY
WHAT WE ARE DOING TO WORK TO
REMOVE ANY MORE EMBARRASSMENT,
AND HE SAID THAT THIS IS A
DECISION THAT HE MADE ON HIS
OWN.
>> NOW, THAT WAS IN REFERENCE TO
THE EFFORT OF THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WHO TRIED TO REMOVE
ILHAN OMAR FROM THE HOUSE
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE OVER HER PAST
REMARKS AND THERE HAS BEEN
CRITICISM FROM THE DEMOCRATS
THAT THEY ARE ALLOWING SANTOS TO
SERVE ON THESE COMMITTEES